erbotschafter Herr Melnik wie dicht
stehen wir aktuell vor einem großen
Krieg ich glaube dass unsere
Fingerspitzen schon wirklich vor diesem
schrecklichen Abgrund des neuen großen
Krieges stehen
das Gefühl ist
unterirdische auch bei meinen Freunden
jetzt zu Hause in Kiefer in der Ukraine
die Menschen haben eine große Angst dass
das Putin diesen Krieg tatsächlich jetzt
in der nächsten Tagen von zahnberichte
und deswegen muss man gerade jetzt
solange es noch nicht zu späteste
handeln und deswegen möchte ich auch
wieder an die Bundesregierung können
appellieren an unsere Freunde im Westen
es ist jetzt an der Seite dass man
tatsächlich diese präventiven Maßnahmen
einleitet dass man die Sanktionen
endlich beschließt bevor der Beschuss
von Kiefer stattfindet bevor
Zivilisten zu Tode kommen das ist jetzt
das Gebote der Stunde und ich möchte
auch mich an die deutsche Öffentlichkeit
wenden mit der bitte helfen Sie uns
gehen Sie bitte auf die Straße ich
appelliere in die Kirche wir brauchen
das Gebet für den Frieden es sind
wirklich hier die Stunden wo es um Krieg
oder Frieden geht und da müssen wir alle
gemeinsam handeln die Diplomatie hat
noch eine letzte Chance obwohl das
Fenster der Möglichkeiten immer enger
wird das Fenster wird immer enger das
sind dramatische Worte von Botschafter
der Ukraine an uns alle auch hier in
Deutschland Herr Kornblum als
langjähriger US-Botschafter wie groß ist
dieses Fenster die Diplomatie schon oder
ist es im Grunde zumindest aus Putin
Sicht schon dicht schon geschlossen
leider kann man nicht wissen weil Puten
hin und her schwebt manchmal ist ja
etwas eher gesprächsbereit und einmal
nicht so wir ich kann mir mich nur
anschließen was er mir nicht gesagt hat
da wir nicht wissen was Puten eigentlich
vorhat und wenn er einen Krieg anfangen
würde wäre das für Russland vor allem
eine große Katastrophe aber da wir das
nicht wissen müssen wir natürlich alle
uns auf das sozusagen schlimmste
Ergebnisse vorbereiten und wir müssen es
halt alles bleiben wir mussten Russland
unter Druck setzen wir müssen auch
militärische Hilfe an nur keine liefern
und vor allem wir müssen klarstellen
dass wir auf der westlichen Seite auch
die Demokratie in Ukraine unterstützen
und begrüßen das dass du keine auch ein
Teil der westlichen Welt werden will er
steht da kann man jetzt schon sagen dass
zumindest das Treffen von Olaf Scholz
neulich mit Wladimir Putin offenbar
überhaupt keine ja Wirkung Richtung
Deeskalation gebracht hat wie man das
zunächst vermutet hat oder gehofft hatte
das hat keine Deeskalation gebracht
nein das kann man nicht sagen sondern
ich glaube dass es nach wie vor darum
gehen muss alle Möglichkeiten der
Diplomatie zu nutzen dazu nutzt jedes
Gespräch Gespräch dir oder scheiß
geführt hat die Gespräche die Person
geführt hat die Gespräche die
amerikanischen Präsidenten
vermuten sie das oder es ist nicht
erkennbar danach hat es eine weitere
Eskalation gegeben die Manöver
beispielsweise die wir gerade gesehen
haben da diplomatie ist es immer so dass
das etwas ist dass man mit Geduld
betrachten muss und wo wir uns auch
natürlich nicht alle Ergebnisse
öffentlich werden ich glaube das ist
wichtig ist es westliche Bündnis einig
ist das sind wir nach einem was ich weiß
gibt's da große Klarheit dass wir einig
sind da drin und das Ende für Menschen
Gesprächen da russischen Seite sehr
deutlich gemacht wird das ist eine große
Konsequenz für sie hätte wenn Russland
den Krieg eröffnen würde in der Ukraine
Weber als Chef der konservativen im
EU-Parlament Melnik hat das gerade der
ukrainische Botschafter ganz klar
gemacht er sagt wir müssen das jetzt
beschließen wir müssen die Sanktion
jetzt beschließen damit eben keine
weitere Eskalation Eintritt worauf
Wartet Europa
zumindest müssen wir die Rechnung ganz
klar auf den Tisch legen und daran
hapert es in Europa Immanuel macron ist
im Wahlkampf seine Hände sind etwas
gebunden wenn man so formuliert und Olaf
Scholz hat es bisher nicht fertig
gebracht die neuesten zwei Frage
wirklich klar zu thematisieren auf
Washington immer wieder Formulierungen
verwandt die zu Unsicherheit einladen
der Westen macht doch keine
geschlossenen Eindruck und das ist das
größte Problem das wir haben es lädt
Putin geradezu ein jetzt voranzugehen
und deswegen aus unserer Sicht das Sicht
der bürgerlichen im Europäischen
Parlament müssen wir die Rechnung klar
präsentieren das heißt erstens aus dem
zwei steht nicht mehr zur Debatte sollte
es zu Eskalation kommen zweitens
Ausschluss des Bankensystems Russlands
aus dem westlichen Finanzsystemen und
die Vorschläge von Boris Johnson gestern
auf der Sicherheitskonferenz sind da
richtig und das dritte wir müssen
Russland von der Hochtechnologie
abschneiden und wenn wir das ernsthaft
und glaubwürdig Wladimir Putin
vermitteln dann weiß er dass der Preis
hoch wird das offenbar ist noch nicht
passiert
gerade angesprochen ich will ihn einmal
zeigen was er bei der BBC für eine
eindringliche Warnung abgegeben hat
ich muss leider sagen dass der Plan den
wir sehen vom Ausmaß her etwas ist das
wirklich der größte Krieg in Europa seit
1945 sein könnte ich muss leider sagen
dass der Plan den wir sehen vom Ausmaß
her etwas ist das wirklich der größte
Krieg in Europa seit 1945 sein könnte
das Szenario als uns allen ja bewusst
sein muss in diesen Minuten in diesen
Stunden
naja übertreib nicht werden Puten tut
Wasser meint dass er bereit ist zu
machen dann das wird ohne Frage der
größte Krieg nach Europa seit 1945 und
auch eigentlich der weitreichende
Konsequenzen haben würde